now streaming live
all right ready to go great thank you so
good morning this is
um public Hearing in children and family
law as chair of the children and family
law committee I find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covid-19
pandemic and in accord with house rule
67 and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee an
executive session may follow please note
that there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made a available in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general Court's
website the notice for this
meeting notice complies with house rules
in RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
27136 or email
HCS leg. state. n.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled Christina Dyer is the staff
assisting us please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also State whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required under
under the right to know law
representative Alysa please call the
role thank you madam
chair representative D
Simone here I am in the committee room
with other
okila representative
yella it appears he's not there thank
you representative luii I am here in the
committee room with the
other thank
you representative
Bellinger Banger and I'm
in and I'm in the committee room with
the other
representative
cross rep representative cross you know
cross she's saying
cross can you hear
me now you're a little
faint but representative cross is not
here in the room I know that and I don't
see her on the screen I don't see her on
the list representative Lichfield
here I am present and in the legislative
room with the other
Smith representative
alone representative Alisa I'm
here and I'm
alone representative rman
good morning everyone I am here at home
with three remote Learners and my
LEC I am here in my kitchen my dog might
come in and
out thank you
representative was
here good morning I am here in my home
in conquer with my husband and three of
Learners representative
office representative
ill good morning I'm here in stratum in
my home
you representative
rice I am here in the lob in the
committee room with um several
colleagues and Madam chair I've noticed
representative ala you are muted we
you representative Alysia you're muted
you can also hit the space bar
representative Alysia if you want to
speak
briefly I've completed the Roll Call
List did you call Representative
yella because he's appeared now okay
sorry I was late I had
a presentation of my uh Bill I'm here
and my home
alone thank
you thank you representative Alysia
thank you
okay so good morning everyone I am going
to open the public hearing on HB
188 excuse me Madam chair yes can I read
the
mask okay yes one um representative D
Simone is going to read The Mask policy
briefly this mask policy is for when you
are at the
lob um you shall wear your mask
when you're not in your
seat or when you're with not within uh
at least six feet of another person or
if you are in a common area which means
the hallway restroom stairway you shall
wear your
you thank you representative gimon so
our first
speaker on House Bill
188 is representative Paul bur to speak
in support of of his
bill okay let me just find Mr
yet there he is allowed to talk good
morning Mr
bur good
morning as we say can folks hear me
yes thank you representative bur go
ahead okay thank you and uh good morning
everyone I my name is Paul Burch I'm a
representative from chesher one which
encompasses the Connecticut River towns
of wole West Milan Chesterfield and
Hinsdale excuse me excuse me
representative can you just speak a
little louder it's hard for us to hear
you okay glad to do it it's request to
me I will do my best um I am a in my
fifth term and a member of House
Judiciary and people didn't catch it I
represent folks in chesher one along the
Connecticut River which is West Milan
Walpole Chesterfield and Hinsdale
relevant to this I am
also uh the uh Judiciary designate
on judicial Council and which has had
and you will hear a significant role in
the development of
hb1 188 I appreciate the the opportunity
to speak here and I'm as always so
pleased that the chair appears to be in
such good health and that's uh it's good
news for all of us so without further
Ado um
hb1 88 is titled relative to appointment
of council and juvenile court
proceedings and the focus of this bill
is to improve the uh delivery of that
particular service in the juvenile
justice system that is the appointment
of assigned councel when
necessary the um the reason this bill
was
drafted was was that the judicial
Council some time ago commissioned a
report uh that was to
analyze the uh the
the affording of council to juveniles in
the juvenile justice system and how
effective that has been that job was
done by the national juvenile Defender
Center
and I have sent and hopefully you have
all received a copy of that report in
some respects if you read the report you
probably don't have to listen to me but
um given how busy we are shall we say uh
you get me to give the uh the head note
version okay as a result of receiving
this report which had maybe 50 or so Rec
recommendations for improving the
delivery of legal services to juveniles
in the Juvenile Justice System uh at the
suggestion of the Judiciary chair then
Marjorie Smith I formed a working group
uh to see what we could do to take these
um proposals and see what would stand a
chance of passing and being enacted in
New Hampshire it was a uh a
distinguished group of Republicans and
Democrats uh lawyers and non- lawyers it
included then Judiciary chair margerie
Smith and now Jud and and the current
Judiciary chair um representative Gordon
who's also a retired
judge um representative Waltz was on
that who's been a prior chair of
Children and Family Law um
representative long was was kept
apprised from time to time about this
and uh representative L contributed to
that group also the group met numerous
times both with the judici uh I was
interfacing with judicial councel we met
with practitioners we met with court
people we met with providers we met with
a representative of the juvenile
Defender system and we put this bill
together I want to briefly say
that there are a whole host of areas
that we decided not to touch just
because it was too big and ask we are
not dealing with the issue of detention
hearings diversion we're not talking
about use of Lost students at in the
diversion process we're not talking
about
police uh use of police as
prosecutors we're not talking about
school resource officers which is a big
issue uh we decided not to get into the
issue of certification of of children to
adult court and we didn't get into the
establishment of performance and other
standards um so if you think this bill
accomplishes a lot there's a whole lot
more that we decided not to focus on so
the major areas that this bill deals
with the first and perhaps the most
important is to require appointment of
council when the petition is
filed and that's when the court gets the
paperwork it's expected at that point
the court will assign Council to the
juvenile
and that means prior to the first
Hearing in court there is required to
have an opportunity for the Juvenile and
Council to
consult the notice to assign council is
to be provided the same day as a
petition is filed and that can be done
electronically
telephone um carrier pigeon St Bernard
whatever it may be uh the idea is to get
that done as Fair as possible so that
some communication between attorney and
the juvenile can occur before getting to
court
and while a juvenile and a parent or
Guardian can wave
Council we do have a mandatory provision
that that can't be done until and unless
the Juvenile and the parent or Guardian
has an opport has had an opportunity to
discuss the wisdom of waiver with
Council now our current statute has some
of these Provisions in it they're not
necessarily widely used for instance
there is a provision where a juvenile
with his or her parents can consult with
an attorney about getting counsel at no
fee the fee the cost of that would be
buil to the judicial Council our
information is that is rarely if ever
used and that seems to be a problem in a
lot of areas in our current juvenile law
there may be Provisions they're not
often used so by getting Council
appointed
early right off the bat then a lot of
other things fall into place there's one
tweak that may get mentioned later and
that is and that may require a small
Amendment or not depending how the
judicial branch looks at it and that is
if the court doesn't have sufficient
information at the filing of the
petition time to decide whether the
juvenile is indent or not uh the
appointment should be considered
provisional and subject to the uh Court
reviewing that at a later date and it's
the same thing as if somebody is
appointed counsel and the person you
know uh wins the lottery the court can
always
go back and say well you no longer need
the services of a paid for lawyer so if
that needs to be clarified and it's not
sure that it does that's that's a small
tweet that can be
made the second big area of the uh bill
is to require Council to be available
for
consultation if there's to be police
interrogation of a
child uh uh the preliminary material to
the bill before the actual working part
the Preamble makes mention of the
Supreme Court's point of view it's US
Supreme Court's point of view is that
children do not feel that they can just
terminate an interview with the police
or walk out when the police are uh
talking to them children are different
than adults so that becomes basic
basically a custodial situation it isn't
a whole lot different than Miranda it's
basically Miranda and what this bill
says is
that if it doesn't bar the police from
talking to the child it simply says that
anything said by the child if that child
has not had an opportunity to consult
with a lawyer cannot be used against
that child in a further uh and a
prosecution of the
child uh the implementation of that is
being
left um to be worked out
administratively how that Council would
be uh practically done may be different
in Manchester and Nashua where an
attorney might be nearby and can
physically go over it might be quite
different in uh in the more rural parts
of the state in the northern part of the
state and that consultation with an
attorney can be done
telephonically uh if privacy is ensured
and other protections are there so the
principle of it is set out in the
statute and I think the judicial branch
and the judicial Council and uh
interested stakeholders can work out how
that would be done
administratively the um the third major
area is that the fee for
councel for appointed counsel in
juvenile cases would be
ended now a characteristic of our
Juvenile justice system is that the
parents pay at virtually every stage of
the
process and what it means is a lot of
those stages aren't
accomplished because the parents cannot
will not choose not to pay for instance
there is on the books a right to appeal
if if you have a bad decision in your
opinion in juvenile court um you have a
right to appeal that but a parent would
have to pay
$2,000 so out of the thousands and
thousands and thousands of cases that
occur
annually I think there have been four
appeals in five years so you can have an
appeal right on the books but it doesn't
really
exist we didn't want to go through
despite the
recommendations from the report and
eliminate all of the parental payments
uh throughout the entire line of of of
the juvenile case we thought that was
too big and ask um so what we're doing
here is saying the right to
counil for that
kid is not going to be dependent on
whether the parents can or want to pay
for their kids lawyer the kid is
entitled to that it's a kid that's going
to go through all the processing and the
kid is going to go through everything
else and um that's an important um right
of of that child and I want to emphasize
at this point that what we're talking
about here are constitutionally required
rights
we're not talking about what would be
nice to have and what's not nice to have
and what be what would be cool and not
cool uh the right to council for
juveniles and Juvenile Justice is
constitutionally required under the
United States
Constitution and that means to put it
frankly the best way to see that that's
effectuated is through the legislature
as opposed to going through the courts
we are the people's uh Representatives
it's also cheaper more effective and
more nuanced I think if if we as
legislators do that um the second thing
I wanted to point as long as I'm taking
a little side trip is we hear a lot of
anecdotal evidence in New Hampshire and
this is true in a lot of States we get
bills that come up and people come come
in and tell anecdotes and I listen to a
lot of the bail Reform Commission uh
hearings and you would get people coming
in and saying well my experience is this
my experience is that and she from what
I see everybody's back out on the
streets 10 days later and somebody else
comes in and everybody is locked up and
nobody's out on the
streets the data here and the the
information here is backed up by data
not
anecdotes and later on today a
representative or this morning a
representative of the national juvenile
Defender Center who put the report
together will in fact talk about
specifics of our Juvenile Justice
program so you know that we're talking
about something that's fact-based rather
than anecdotal
based one last area and um
uh will be which will also be
discussed is we will be eliminating that
by this bill flat fee cont contracts for
representation of juveniles by private
Council what we have as a system now
which is not all that common in uh in
how these are set up with other agencies
is a lawyer has paid a flat fee to
handle a certain class of cases and it's
not dependent on how complicated the
case is or the amount of work required
for that case and unfortunately what
that means is if a lawyer is getting
paid $300 to handle a
case the client's going to get $300
worth of work whether the case requires
$300 worth of work or $1,500 worth of
work I mean that's just the reality of
of real life so um the recommendation
from the national juvenile Defender
Center and consistent with what happens
in in in most contracts in the state uh
of this nature payment of assigned coun
will be based on an hourly rate and that
would be decided by the judicial branch
so uh and that would presumably be in
Conformity with how it's done with other
uh similar
circumstances so those are the major
areas of what this bill does and it
basically will
ensure that council is there
sooner that Council has effective time
to talk to
clients that oh there's one other area
to mention the bill also makes it clear
that representation shall be on all
matters related to the subject matter of
the
petition so that if there are
um uh appeals if there are collateral
placement issues that that attorney
who's already familiar with the case
continues to work on the case but we put
a limitation in saying it has to be
within the subject matter of the
petition for instance the juvenile may
also have let's say an IEP
issue nothing to do with the petition or
why the child is in juvenile justice
system this does not mean that an
attorney is mandated to be appointed for
that child for the purposes of IEP
proceedings representation shall be full
and wholesome for everything that has to
do with the subject matter of the
petition and of the petition only and
the last thing I want to do before I
turn it over to some others and answer
any questions is to note that the major
recommendation from the national
juvenile Defender Center was to to
completely switch over the system to one
of specialized attorneys handling
juvenile matters
exclusively and in many respects that is
the best
practice uh because if you have highly
trained Specialists many of these
changes will flow from that however that
seemed to be in an age of budget crisis
and other issues um an unrealistic ask
to reform the system in that matter so
what we've decided to do uh in our
working group was to say okay we're not
going to uh toss out the whole old
system and put in a new best practices
system we are going to try to make at
least the necessary changes to keep the
car on the road and that's what we're
trying to do here I do want to say and
give credit to the judicial Council
that although we are not in this bill
talking about establishing State
qualifications and performance standards
that there is a serious effort by the
judicial Council to continue with
improve and make ongoing uh the training
of lawyers who handle juvenile cases
that is ongoing it has been ongoing and
it will be ongoing and and I think
mention needs to be made of that so
that's my overview I know I spoke for a
while and um if there are questions I'm
happy to answer if not there's some more
people who can give specific
answers thank you representative Burch
are there any questions from the
committee
yella hi thank you uh for recognizing me
and thank thank you for taking the
question um
is
this you mentioned the constitutionality
of required uh right to counsel
and is it your understanding that that
requirement is
for criminal
cases or um strictly or also for civil
cases and what does this fall under and
uh is there a
requirement seeming requirement in this
bill to uh allow or require the
opportunity for for representation in
civil cases thank you thank you for your
question representative and it's a good
one
um in in juvenile land uh it's referred
to as delinquency cases as uh juveniles
presumably cannot commit crimes they do
delinquent acts but but the same concept
this bill relates only to the
delinquency aspects and I think the
Constitutional mandate on those is
absolutely clear um how I personally
believe that the Liberty interests are
such in children in need cases that an
argument can be made that there are um
constitutional requirements but I'm not
making that argument today for civil
today but I'd be glad to visit with you
further okay are there any further
questions representative lewicki thank
you madam chair um I don't see a fiscal
note attached to this uh do we have a
good idea of uh any idea of how much
it's going to cost and how to
money all right um no there is no fiscal
note and
um uh the representative from the
judicial Council will speak a bit as to
the costs of this bill in many of the
changes we'll have very little Financial
impact uh having a council appointed
sooner rather than later has very very
little
impact um one area that may have an
impact is in the uh assigning of council
or the
um uh provision of council to a juvenile
who's being questioned if it's done by
telephone or similar means the cost
would be fairly minimal if it's done by
having a public defender head over to
the police station and uh that's going
to entail greater cost the um the
overall costs I don't think are going to
be huge but someone else will be
representative okay and just a reminder
though that we we vote on the policy not
the price pack that goes along with it
we vote whether or not we support the
policy going forward not the financial
aspect of it are there any more
bur okay seeing none thank you very much
representative
Birch and up next
is Christina Gilbert a member of the
public who is representing the national
juvenile Defender Center to speak in
support of the
Bill thank you can you hear me yes great
uh thank you so much chairwoman rice and
members of the committee thank you for
giving the national juvenile Defender
Center and jdc the opportunity to
provide this testimony on hb18 and how
it comports with National Best Practices
regarding appointment of Council in
juvenile court my name is Christina
Gilbert I'm a senior staff attorney and
policy counsel at njdc uh njdc is a
nonprofit partis an organization
dedicated to promoting justice for all
children by ensuring excellence in
juvenile defense we believe that all
youth have the right to Ardent
well-resourced representation and we
work to improve access to and quality of
counsel for all young people in
delinquency Court we provide technical
assistance training and support to
juvenile defense attorneys across the
country and support the reform of court
systems and policies that negatively
impact our nation's youth we've also
supported effective and developmentally
appropriate juvenile court reform
through assessments of access to and
quality of juvenile defense council at
the state level to date we've done 28
assessments including the release of our
New Hampshire assessment last August
which I believe you all have our work in
both New Hampshire and nationally
provides us with a unique perspective on
appointment of Council in juvenile court
and the efforts to protect the due
process rights of Youth across the
country we support efforts to ensure
children are afforded legal counsel at
the earliest possible interaction with
the legal system and throughout the time
of Court involvement HB 188 is an
important First Step requiring the
appointment of council once a
delinquency petition has been filed or
summoned issued and before the child
appears in court moreover requiring that
young people can consult with councel
prior to waving the right to counsel is
vital to doe process protections the
provision prohibiting admittance of a
statement from an unrepresented minor in
any judicial proceeding is also critical
to ensuring young people's rights we
also support the other provisions of HB
188 that were mentioned
um here but because this bill covers
such a range and there will be others
speaking I'll limit my remarks to the
appointment of council more than 50
years ago the United States Supreme
Court issued in ralt a landmark decision
declaring that children require The
Guiding hand of council at every step in
the proceedings this vital
constitutional right to councel must
begin prior to the child's first
appearance in court since G state
legislator and courts have grappled with
how to implement that right for a
population that is developmentally
different than adults and need
safeguards to protect their rights too
often in courts across our country and
in New Hampshire a Defender will not
meet their client until the first
appearance at the courthouse if they are
lucky the defender and child might have
five to 10 minutes to discuss the case
in the upcoming hearing if they're not
so lucky the defender might get only a
few whispered comments to their new
client while standing at Council table
just before the hearing begins this
Falls far short of what the Constitution
requires of the right to councel if
council is not appointed until the first
court parents the child and their family
must walk into the courthouse with
little to no understanding of what is
happening leaving them overwhelmed and
Confused one of our key findings in our
New Hampshire assessment was that the
appointment system does not provide
counsil to youth early enough as a
result they may appear at their initial
court hearing without counsel and enter
pleas without ever Consulting with an
attorney in our assessment we make the
recommendation to automatically
appointment appoint Council for all
youth before their first court
appearance and ensure their represented
throughout their involvement in the
legal system
hpb18 requirement that the appointment
of council shall be made sufficiently
before any hearing to allow for
consultation between councel and client
as well as for any appropriate
investigation is an important step
toward ensuring that young people have
the opportunity to fully participate in
their own defense which is what the
Constitution
requires in recognition of the
developmental differences of young
people New Hampshire has already put
some safeguards in place severely
limiting how and when a young person may
wave their right to counsel however njdc
OB erve through our assessment that in
some jurisdictions many children were
still waving their right to counsel and
pleading at arraignment without ever
Consulting with with counsel about their
right to an attorney HB 188 would add
the additional safeguards necessary to
ensure that all children in New
Hampshire regardless of jurisdiction
receive the benefit of this
protection involvement in the
delinquency system can create a
multitude of barriers to a Young
Person's future opportunities for
employment housing and education
juvenile defense attorneys can play a
significant role in helping eliminate
such barriers
comprehensive representation by juvenal
defense attorneys encompasses a wide
range of in and outof Court advocacy
currently under New Hampshire law
representation for youth in delinquency
proceedings automatically ends 30 days
after disposition unless a post-d
dispositional motion is filed within
that time frame the provision of HB 1888
that requires representation include
related proceedings related to the same
factual circumstances allows for more
holistic advocacy by attorneys um which
allows for continued communication and
Report building which is Critical with
young clients finally we also support
the prision excuse me um The Proposition
that uh not only that children have
sufficient opportunity to consult with
counsel before any statement or
confession is obtained by law
enforcement um that that may not be used
in court developmental research suggests
youth may be more susceptible than
adults to interrogation pressures
because they are less likely to
understand legal process or their rights
have less impulse control and are more
prone to risky decision making are more
susceptible to immediate rewards and
have more difficulty in anticipating the
consequences of their actions they're
more likely to comply with authority and
are more susceptible to Pure influence
based on the existing research it's
clear that special caution is required
when interroga you requiring access to
and consultation with councel prior to
the use of any confession or statement
obtained by law enforcement upholds
children's constitutional right to
counsel and ensures the Integrity of
Investigations involving children as
long ago as 1948 the Supreme Court
asserted we cannot believe that a lad of
Tender Years is a match for the police
in such a contest he needs counsel and
support if he is not to become the
victim first of fear then of panic more
recently the Supreme Court held the age
informs the Miranda analysis for
custodial interrogations because
children subjected to police questioning
often feel more pressured to comply with
authority than adults the Supreme Court
aply stated by its very nature custodial
police interrogation entails inherently
compelling pressure
even for an adult the physical and
psychological isolation of custodial
interrogation can undermine the
individual's will to resist and compel
him to speak where he would not
otherwise do so freely this bill would
assist children in understanding their
rights in the legal process before they
are subject to the overpowering presence
of the law Studies have found that in
the absence of council almost 90% of the
children wave their Miranda rights with
few children understanding the rights
they're waving this leaves children
literally defenseless in the face of
trained professionals seeking to secure
confessions HB 188 will afford children
earlier access to counsel throughout New
Hampshire and provide the child and
attorney proper time for consultation
before any court hearing njdc strongly
supports HB 188 and respectfully urges
the L legislator's support thank you and
I'm ha we'll be submitting written
testimony with additional details um and
support and I'm happy to answer any
questions now as
well great thank you so much are there
yella you're there hi thank you and uh
thank you for taking the question um in
the assessment that you uh created did
you find
any conclusions that are um contrary to
the stated mission of the group that you
um
represent I'm not sure I entirely and uh
understand your question so you you made
um a bunch of statements about what what
the goal of your um group is yes and the
state Mission and then you made an
assessment on New Hampshire and I'm
wondering if you found anything
um unusual or um contrary to your State
admission in the assessment of New
Hampshire sure and I can say you know
our assessment we can't go to Every
court and every jurisdiction so there
are certainly limitations um
however we found a lot of strength there
are a lot of strengths in New Hampshire
to the juvenile defense system what we
primarily found were a lot of systemic
barriers to um I think in New
Hampshire most people working in the
juvenile justice system and the juvenile
defense system uh had the goal of
excellence in juvenile defense and
promoting Justice for children and
ensuring the constitutional right to
counsel I should say in our interviews
across stakeholder groups judges
Defenders probation officers um the
majority of people we talked to saw no
reason that Council couldn't be at um
appointed earlier and thought that
children needed it um so I think a lot
of what we found were more systemic
barriers uh getting in the way of um you
mission thank
you any further questions from members
committee thank you very much Miss
next up is U Michael
Skiby a lobbyist with the disability
rights Center to speak in support of the
Bill thank you madam chair can you hear
me yes thank you good morning uh my name
is Michael Skiby I'm the policy director
at the disability rights Center I appear
on behalf of the disability rights
Center and on behalf of the juvenile
reform project which as many of you are
familiar with it's a coalition of groups
that have been involved in uh reform of
the juvenile justice system over several
years it includes New Hampshire legal
assistance my office the ACLU of New
Hampshire Waypoint and new
futures um my experience uh earlier in
my career um involved a fair amount of
involvement in the Juvenile Justice
System I spent the first 17 years of my
career at the public defender program as
a lawyer as a supervisor and ultimately
as director of the program um I've also
been a consultant on Indigent defense
issues in California and
Pennsylvania I'd like to begin my
testimony just by talking about um how
pervasive disability is in the juvenile
justice justice system and that's really
why my office has been involved in these
reform efforts for so long um most
research um focuses on the population of
children that end up in facilities where
most information is more information is
available than just children who show up
in court and that research is really
striking it shows that about 70% of kids
or more in juvenile facilities have
disabilities typically behavioral
disorders but a wide range of
disabilities um it may even be higher in
New Hampshire I was present at a
legislative hearing two years ago where
representatives of the Department of
Health and Human Services said that
fully 100% of the children at the suu
center in Manchester um had a disability
of one sort or another
now the high representation of kids with
disabilities in the Juvenile Justice
System um is due to a variety of reasons
and Dynamics one is as you might imagine
um when someone has a disability they
often experience School failure and
alienation from peers that might be you
know positive influences if they weren't
alienated from them um alienation from
coaches teachers other non-parent adults
they may have difficulty with impulse
control they may have difficulty
understanding and conforming to rules
and structures that they're subjected to
um may be difficulty difficult for them
to uh consider the consequences of their
behaviors um and also they may have more
difficulty than their peers at
misbehaving successfully if you will
they tend to be pretty
unsuccessful um uh uh actors when it
comes to violating the law and it's very
difficult for them to get away with it
as compared to kids without disabilities
the other thing that I think is very
important to think about is that there's
pretty good evidence that there that
kids with disabilities are processed in
the system differently they tend to have
more difficulty um dealing with
encounters with authority figures
including teachers dealing with
discipline issues police prosecutors and
judges after they may become involved in
the system and that's part of the reason
that you see kids getting kids with
disabilities getting deeper and deeper
into the system um as compared to their
non-disabled peers so this this High
rate of disability is extremely
important to consider when you're
thinking about the importance of having
trained and skilled lawyers involved in
the system to assist these children um
as early as possible and throughout
their involvement in the system turning
to the to a couple of specific portions
of the bill um first I wanted to address
um the the section that eliminates the
use of flat fee contracts which is
section seven on page three line 10 now
the the Indigent defense system for both
adults and children in New Hampshire
basically has three principle components
the vast majority of cases are handled
by the public defender program which is
a large nonprofit Law Firm that has a
contractual relationship with the state
it has lawyers on staff um they don't
charge the state on a perase basis they
basically have a large contract that
provides for a certain number of lawyers
throughout the state to handle a variety
of cases the second tier of the system
handles the most of the remainder of the
cases and that's a a contractual system
where private lawyers enter into
contracts with the state through the
judicial Council to provide cases in
various categories and they do that for
a flat fee that is for a misdemeanor you
get a certain number of hundreds of
dollars for a felony a couple of
thousand dollars I don't really know
what the number is anymore um and for
juveniles it's a flat fee as
well um there's a very small number of
cases that are also handled on an hourly
rate but the system really has very few
of those left most of the cases are
handled by these previous two components
I mentioned now the problem as you can
imagine is that a flat fee means that
every action that you take reduces your
hourly rate that you're actually being
paid because regardless of whether you
spent 20 hours on a case or three hours
on a case you're getting the same amount
of money so the incentives are all in
the wrong direction now the hourly rates
that that the system pays for lawyers
hand handling cases on an hourly basis
either in the criminal system or other
parts of our system are way below what
lawyers typically make and long ago they
were surpassed by the average overhead
rate of a New Hampshire Law Firm but at
least when you get those low hourly
rates you get paid more for more work
that doesn't happen with the flat fee
system now in addition to this setting
the flat fee is just
inherently um a a blunt instrument
because the of the case are highly
variable
andby M giby you're fading a little bit
can you just speak up a little bit for
us all right sorry about that um it's
highly dependent on what kinds of legal
issues are in the case the facts of the
case whether the minor has a disability
and how complex that disability is um
that may involve evaluations Consulting
with experts doing research outside the
the uh the law the actions of the
prosecution and of the judge can can
trigger ex extra effort on the part of
the defense so it's extremely difficult
uh to predict at the outset what these
kinds of cases are gonna are gonna um
are gonna take in terms of efforts so
any system that uses a flat rate is
likely to undercompensated lawyers in a
vast not a majority of cases but a
significant fraction of those cases um
so that's those are my comments about
the flat rate system I urge you to um
adopt that portion of the bill
um so that uh lawyers are paid more for
more work um next I want to talk about
the early appointment section which is
section two which it's sections two
through four both of all of which are on
page two now when a delinquency case is
begun in New Hampshire there's really no
lawyer until the first time that the
family and the child show up in court
the only exceptions for that is if a
lawyer is hired by the family that's a
very small fraction of the cases or if
the police are asking the judge to lock
the kid up at the sununu center at the
very beginning of the case the law in
those cases requires that that a lawyer
be called over to represent the kid at
that particular hearing but typically a
child will go to court without a lawyer
and that and with little or no
understanding of what is about to happen
oftentimes they're accompanied by
parents who are pretty unhappy with the
child's Behavior they might have taken a
day off of work they may not be focused
on protecting the child's rights but on
making the child face the consequences
of their actions
um in addition they're walking into a
system that is a competitive adversary
process just like the adult Criminal
Justice System um For Better or Worse
some people think for worse but For
Better or Worse that's the system we
have and the people on the other side of
the case are looking to Prevail in the
case um the consequences of these cases
can be profound even lifelong um and
parents walk into these into these um
cour houses without lawyers for
themselves or their children uh often
times wanting to be cooperative but
really not understanding the
consequences that uh May flow to their
children um the process can be
confusing prosecutors have an in
incentive to get the cases over with but
not have to come back later and bring in
Witnesses uh it may be difficult for
families to understand what information
is important to give to the judge and
significant decisions are made on that
first day the decision to either place
the child outside the home or allow them
to um continue living at home while the
case is pen
what sorts of conditions of release um
it's a very quite significant profound
day in the case uh so this proposal
would immediately assign Council when
the petition is filed this will make the
system much more fair and protect the
rights of
children having a lawyer though at that
first at that first day in court can
really make the system more fair um and
more efficient because it can reduce the
use of unnecessary restrictive
placements when they're not appropriate
and that can save the state money
um related to this is what uh
representative Burch mentioned is this
issue of indigency um you'll see that in
in the provisions on that page there's a
limitation in the current law to
basically only assigning Council to
Indigent children which basically means
a child that can't hire Counsel on their
own um and the way that this is
typically handled in the current system
is that paperwork is filled out about
the family's um Financial um status and
the judge makes an assessment as to
whether the family can afford to hire
counsel in juvenile cases um it's the
child itself that is supposed to be able
to um hire counsel so as you can imagine
very close to 100% of court involved
children are Indigent but the system
works now that you don't really get your
lawyer until you fill out the paperwork
so that's not a big deal now but if
we're going to sign councel when the
when the petition is filed it's
important that this paperwork not be an
impediment to that so I'd ask you that
you can consider modifying that language
and if the court is inclined if the
committee is inclined to do that I have
a some proposed language to change that
those sections that I can provide to the
chair so I've just focused on a few
parts of the bill my colleague Michelle
wangren of New Hampshire legal
assistance is also signed up to testify
about a couple of other parts I would
urge you to pass this bill it's a bill
that will protect the rights of children
improve the outcomes for children and
and along the way I think it improves
Public Safety and well-being and I think
it'll make the system work more
efficiently and cost effectively I'd be
happy to answer any
questions thank you Mr Skiby are there
Skiby seeing none thank you very
much so we have five more speakers on
this bill and we have until 10:45 I'd
like to not run really late so just
please keep that in mind um up next is
Sarah blet with the judicial Council to
bill good morning Madame chair this is
Sarah blogic can you hear me yes yes
thank you thank you uh thank you madam
chair and committee members for taking
my testimony today
I'm Sarah blet I'm the executive
director of the judicial Council and the
council is the state agency that is
responsible for ensuring the quality and
the coste effectiveness of indigent
defense the council members met on
Tuesday to review this bill although we
did not have a full Quorum um the
members with the exception of the
Circuit Court member who abstained
voted in favor of supporting this bill
if it includes a fiscal note um because
we anticipate a significant increase in
Indigent defense expenditures if this
bill is passed and wanted to be very
upfront about the costs that we see but
as you've heard from previous uh
testimony the judicial Council has
received this assessment from the
national juvenile Defender center it's
very clear to our members
that the representation of juveniles has
evolved significantly over the past
several years and the national trend is
to provide a more holistic model of
representation um the assessment was
very eye openening for our members and
we've been working closely with the
national juvenile Defender Center and
other stakeholders to address some of
the issues that were
raised
um we were actually in the process of
applying for a Federal grant that will
give us some financial assistance for
training programs and to initiate a
pilot program with a social worker who
specializes in juvenile
representation and the national juvenile
Defender Center has been working with us
on that
application this Bill does an excellent
job of addressing some of the most
important findings of the assessment um
and as as you've heard and as you see
the sponsors were very thoughtful in
their approach to these various issues
um the judicial Council feels very
strongly that a fiscal note is needed
because although the policy is supported
we want the legislature to be aware of
the price tag for this
you've heard quite a bit of testimony
about the concerns with the flat fee
reimbursement model for our contract
attorney program and right now a
contract attorney is paid the same
amount for a juvenile case whether it's
a simple misdemeanor Criminal Trespass
or one of the most serious charges in
our criminal code and aggravated
felonius sexual assault the flat fee
reimbursement model was actually
implemented when the previous governor
sonunu was in office and it was done as
a way to contain costs for the layer of
cases that cannot be handled by the
public defender
program and in the last fiscal year we
paid approximately
$45,000 for contract attorneys to
represent juveniles to switch to an
hourly rate reimbursement based on those
numbers would result in a increase of
approximately 200 to $300,000 more
dollars for that system and I think
everybody who's spoken before me has
been very eloquent about the drawbacks
of a flat fee system we use that system
in our adult criminal matters as well um
certainly it is now a dis favored uh
reimbursement model you've heard the
issues with it and although it does come
with a significant cost the council
feels strongly that this bill with an
appropriate
appropriation um would really go a long
way to addressing one of the biggest
concerns that the national juvenile
Defender Center
raised costs for earlier appointment of
council are not expected to be
significant at all as you've heard from
representative bur there would be costs
associated with Council
representing juveniles who are being
interrogated or questioned by the police
and there would also be a cost um for
representation in related matters so
although the policy is very important
and very important to the judicial
councel they did direct me to make it
very clear that they believe this needs
a fiscal note so that all of you can see
what the cost would
be um I I want to thank the sponsors of
the bill because this really I know a
lot of time and thought went into this
their approach really was laser beam
focused on the biggest issues that we
are are facing our Juvenile justice
system today I won't take a lot more
time I know you have several other
people to hear from but the the public
policy piece of this thing is really
crucial in terms of moving forward with
our representation and enhancing it in
the ways that we are being advised to do
and so the council is ready to make
these changes but want you to be aware
of that fiscal impact and I'm happy to
take any questions that you may
have thank you Miss blet are there any
questions from committee
members seeing none thank you very much
thank you so much for your
time next up is representative Mary Beth
walls to speak in
favor of the um
Bill I'm here can you hear me yes thank
you thank you um I too am cognizant of
the time and I will try to be brief here
um I just wanted to talk about some of
the major points and highlight this
first of all with respect to What Sarah
blet Said I now sit on finance I happen
to sit on division one where I oversee
the judicial council's budget we would
welcome a fiscal note that would help us
determine what the appropriate amount is
so I think that would be terrific um uh
more generally I wanted to talk about
the fact of of where representative
Burch started with this this has been a
constitutional mandate since
1967 this is not something that is
optional and in fact New Hampshire is
probably facing the threat of yet more
litigation because we are not
appropriately providing Council for
juveniles and litigation is just going
to cost us money sometimes spending
money saves US money and this is one of
those examples we're spending a little
bit more money here to provide
appropriate Council will actually save
us money in the long run um we also know
that early appointment is the best for
the children for the parents and for the
lawyers trying to represent them it
yields better and cheaper
results and it's very important that
there be no reimbursement option or
requirement I mean for the kids what
happens is when you have a reimbursement
option for the juveniles it means the
parents are effectively paying it and
they often push a child to to enter a
plea or not to take other options
available to them because they don't
want to be stuck with the cost and in
fact even the C the cost of a juvenile
diversion program which is only
$100 sometimes that's too much for a
family and a parent will turn down that
option because they're not interested in
paying even a mere $100 for a diversion
program um we also want to confirm that
um the right to counil should not be
controlled by a family's wealth or by
geography so parents with Mone
can go out and get private counsel or
pay these fees where children from more
impoverished families don't have that
option and don't receive the same
quality counsel um in fact parents have
a conflict of interest because it's the
parents interest to pay the least amount
possible it's the child's interest to
get the best representation possible and
those often end up in
Conflict um we also know I sat a year
ago on a committee that looked at the
recovery from the office of uh Cost
Containment and learned that the office
of cross containment just about breaks
even that with the amount of money that
they seek from defendants both juveniles
and adults to pay for lawyers and the
amount of cost to run that office is
nearly identical um and all honesty
there is a slight uh net intake there
but it's so small as to really be
meaningless and in all honesty the
finance committee has looked at
eliminating the office of Cost
Containment because the recovery Y is so
low
um there are costs that we often don't
think of that come with this besides
lawyers and a diversion program um the
cost of
Investigations uh the cost of having
experts there are a number of costs that
representation uh finally I just want to
talk about that these choices have
lifelong consequences for these children
you heard testimony earlier that it
affects employment housing and education
and what happens is is that uh the
choices made here really determine
whether or not a child stays in the
system and a child who stays in the
system is not contributing to society
and that in the end ends up costing us
more money so once again not only is
this more fair and more just and more
constitutional but it really is a
cost-saving for the state of New
Hampshire thank you and I'll take any
questions if anybody has
any thank you representative walls are
there any questions for representative
walls No Hands seeing none thank you
thank you up next is Katherine Cooper
with the New Hampshire Association of
criminal defense lawyers to speak in
support of the bill um thank you madam
chairman and members of the committee my
name is Katherine Cooper and I appear
here today um virtually on behalf of the
New Hampshire Association of criminal
defense lawyers um we don't testify too
often in front of your committee so I
would just like to explain that we are
we are a professional association of
more than 250 Granite State lawyers who
practice um criminal defense and
juvenile defense around the state and
our membership includes both private
practitioners and state and federal
public
defenders um I'm going to be honest um I
don't have a lot to add and I'm going to
um make my time here very brief because
we are really in agreement with um the
testimony of Mr Skiby um representative
walner and also the speaker from the
national juvenile Defender Center I am
going to submit some written testimony
however and that testimony includes a
couple of stories at the end um that I
hope that you can take a moment to
review because um in preparing for this
I spoke with several attorneys both
public defenders and private lawyers who
um practice regularly in the juvenile
courts and I think that these stories
really demonstrate um the need for
ongoing um and early representation um
on the part of the children in the state
so I'm going to leave it at that unless
anyone has any specific questions for me
and I will be submitting my testimony to
you in
writing thank you than you very much are
there any questions from Miss Cooper I
see no hands seeing none thank you very
much thank
you up next is Michelle wangren with New
Hampshire legal assistance to speak in
support of the bill I have to find her
she madam sh if she could spell her last
name please when she she arrives pardon
me if she could uh spell her last name
oh it's it's up w a n g r i n i see on
folks she has a hand raised yep she's
list she's on the screen and ready to go
thank
you can you all hear me yes thank you
okay good morning Madam chair and
members of the committee my name is
Michelle wangren and I'm the youth Law
Project Director at New Hampshire legal
assistance through that role I represent
at risk and system involved youth to
help ensure their educational and other
needs are met and reduce the need for
court involvement prior to my role at
nhla I was an attorney at the New
Hampshire public defender and frequently
represented youth charged with
delinquency offenses I appear today on
behalf of nhla as well as the juvenile
reform project which you heard about
from Mike Skiby while I support this
bill in its entirety to prevent
duplicating testimony this morning I
want to focus on two key pieces of
legislation section 4 paragraph 1A and
section six so section four paragraph 1
a starts on page two line 24 and it
really does two things first it allows
defense attorneys to participate in
ancillary proceedings when those
proceedings are based on the same
factual circumstances as the delinquency
petition and then second it extends the
appointment of council until the
juvenile's case closes regarding the
ancillary proceedings simply put this
provision permits defense councel to use
their judgment to ensure they provide
youth effective assistance of councel
without any arbitrary barriers rule 1.1
of the attorney rules of professional
conduct requires lawyers to conduct
proper case preparation this includes
inquiry into an analysis of the factual
and legal elements of the case and use
of methods and procedures meeting the
standards of competent practitioners the
njdc report found that New Hampshire
attorneys underutilize investigators to
adequately prepare cases in juvenile
practice extremely valuable information
is often learned and discussed at school
or treatment team meetings particularly
when the delinquency charges stem from
offenses committed at school or within a
residential
placement again while it may not be
necessary or appropriate for the
attorney or investigator to attend all
such meetings it must be within the
attorney's professional judgment to
determine what competence requires in a
given case and without arbitrary con
constraint this provision takes a
critical step in allowing all juvenile
defense attorneys to exercise that
professional judgment for instance under
current standard it standards it's a
violation of conditional release for
youth to be suspended or expelled from
school a youth may have any number of
factual legal or disability based
reasons to over overcome the underlying
expulsion but without legal assistance
available to dispute or at least advise
the youth through that process any
opportunity to dispute the violation of
conditional releases dead in the water
current practice discourages defense
attorneys from even attending ancillary
proceedings such as school discipline
proceedings or related meetings well
it's certainly not necessary to attend
every such proceeding in every case it's
critically important that internal
policies or procedures do not constrain
the professional Judgment of attorneys
to decide what's required in an
individual
case and second section 4 amended
paragraph 1A would require appointment
of council to remain in effect until
keys closure historically in New
Hampshire juvenile cases close within 30
days after the dispositional hearing and
are only reopened immediately before any
subsequent hearings that could be three
or six months down the road at best in
the wake of the covid-19 pandemic this
practice was immediately recognized as
unfathomable as it pertains to youth in
out- of Home placements stakeholders
agreed that that with the added risks of
congregate care placement during the
pandemic are worthy to access to an
attorney but the need for a child's
voice voice after disposition doesn't
stop when the pandemic ends and was
highlighted as a systemic failure in our
state by the national juvenile Defender
Center I'll start by saying that a
child's removal from home is nothing
short of traumatizing regardless of the
circumstances leading to placement it's
often the first time they find
themselves without a friend without a
trusted adult and without the
possibility of even an Embrace by their
family how that child will respond is
unpredictable they could withdraw into
themselves they could begin quietly
self-harming or they could lash out
everyone around them but once their
attorney leaves them there's nobody left
to advocate for them as an attorney
frequently working with youth I know
that even when children are struggling
they forget to reach out to those they
know will advocate for them but if their
attorney checks in with them they will
typically talk freely and gladly accept
help to get out of often dire
circumstances when their behaviors are
perceived as shortcomings of their
character rather than reactions to their
circumstances they may be isolated
restrained or transferred to more and
more restrictive placements even when
these children have involved parents
their parents are not always effective
nor do they have the ability or know how
to access the court if warranted the
child is left with no Advocate to
proactively ensure their needs are met
their services are provided or that they
have keiss plans designed to help them
return home in my practice I've worked
with children who are struggling in
their core ordered residential
placements only to find out necessary
special education services have been
removed to meet the needs of the
placement without any prior discussion
about whether it was an educationally
appropriate placement to begin with even
worse some children's IEPs are sarily
removed altogether shortly after they
enter placement even if a residential
school is able to meet the child's needs
through its nature as a self-contained
special education School removing the
IEP hinders this child's successful
transition back into public school now
while these issues may not be the role
of the attorney to fully resolve
independently discovering that a
placement turns out to be wholly
inappropriate for a child is certainly
worthy of raising with the court
immediately rather than waiting for a
hearing 6 months down the road by which
point the child could have disengaged
altogether or Worse picked up new
charges ensuring the child is in an
appropriate placement is good for the
child good for the family and prevents
waste of State dollars on inappropriate
and ineffective programming the same
holds true for children who have not yet
been removed from their home the very
first stated purpose of RSA 169b is to
facilitate the minor development by
providing the protection care treatment
counseling supervision and
rehabilitative resources that a child
needs
if a child doesn't have access to
appropriate resources research is clear
that they will sink deeper and deeper
into the system a competent and involved
attorney can help ensure they have
access to appropriate Services before
the child reaches a Breaking Point and
faces residential placement minimally
rather than closing the case until the
worst happens the attorney should remain
apprised of the case status and any need
for intervention or court-based
advocacy then the last point that I want
to make today um or actually so the last
Point actually on section four for is
that it's not entirely clear to me what
page two line 30 is designed to address
and representative bur had addressed
this earlier um that that taking on the
added costs may be too big of a lift um
but I do want to just point out that
last year the general court eliminated
the parental reimbursement structure in
juvenile delinquency proceedings and
this bill eliminates the reimbursement
for juvenile Council um so I'm not sure
what costs are left that the juvenile
may be responsible for other than the
possibility of a restitution payment and
if that's the issue that this language
is designed to address I would just
recommend amending the line to take out
costs and fees and to replace it with
restitution if there are other some
other costs that I'm not thinking of
then then that should certainly be
considered as
well and then finally I just want to
touch upon section six which starts at
the top of Page Three the section
prohibits the use of uncons statements
at a juvenile trial and one of the ndc's
greatest concerns about New Hampshire
system was our late appointment of
council with which attorney Skiby spoke
about um earlier and in his testimony
you heard about the need for timely
appointment of Council in an ordinary
case but this provision um section six
provides an added layer of protection
research is clear that kids are
particularly vulnerable to the influence
of adult Authority and do not understand
the implications of making a statement
to the police this is couple by the fact
that children in general and children
with disabilities in particular are much
more likely than adults to face to make
false confessions children easily
believe that if they are just
Cooperative adults and Authority will
help them but oftentimes that's simply
not the case even when children receive
leniency for cooperating they typically
still enter the system and entering the
system exponentially increases the odds
of remaining in it indefinitely dropping
out of school and entering the adult
criminal justice system this provision
would provide the most basic protection
that prior to making an admissible
statement the child would have the right
to consult with
counsel such a consultation would help
them understand if the information
they're providing would be helpful to
the police or incriminating to the child
this is a good thing for the system as
you heard before early appointment of
council helps the system be more
efficient if its information law
enforcement is after an attorney could
help the child negotiate an agreement to
provide that information in exchange for
a developmentally appropriate program
for instance or the attorney could simp
help the child understand the benefits
and consequences of cooperating with an
investigation to ensure the child's
choice is
informed in the interest of time I'm
just going to Li my comments to that but
for all these reasons and all the
reasons you've heard from other
Advocates today I urge this committee to
vote out to pass for HB to on HB 188 and
I'm happy to take any questions that you
may
have thank you very much are there any
long representative long thank you madam
chair uh uh thank you uh Miss
wangelin uh so I was under the
understanding also that last term the
cost the costs are no longer in
effect um so so what you're saying here
to um change on line 30 cost and fees to
restitution um if we change it to just
restitution is there any other fee or
something else that may come up none
that I can think of but again I'm not
sure what the intent of that line was
and so um I don't know if representative
Burch or other members of the judicial
Council had in mind what other costs
that might entail but I can't think of
any costs that would remain other than
restitution to a family okay very good
thank
you thank you are there any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you next up is um Mor O'Neal
the from the New Hampshire Office of the
child advocate but there are two on the
screen I need to know who is who oh
sorry um I'm sorry it's this is I'm moir
O'Neal can you hear me yes thank you
very much we we can't we can't see the
screen so we can't adjust our names okay
and we're on limited time yes thank you
madam chair um it's good to see all the
members of the committee again for the
record I'm Moira O'Neal I'm the State
child advocate um and in the interest of
time I will provide an very abrid
version of the testimony I have already
submitted in writing um this bill has
been well supported this morning in the
and um I just want to reiterate two
areas one is about um understanding the
development of children's brains and
also the circumstances of children and
their families regarding brain
development you heard Mr skibby describe
the high incidents of disability amongst
children involved in the Juvenile
Justice System some would argue that a
naturally undeveloped brain is a kind of
disability in itself and I know many of
you know adolescent boys and girls and
you may agree with me on that um absent
councel the average child is at greater
risk of waving their rights agreeing to
conditions impinging upon their Liberty
or making decisions that significantly
impact their future we know from very
elegant Imaging studies and other
research that the frontal lobe of the
brain including the prefrontal cortex is
still developing well into the mid 20s
so that structure and function of the
that part of the brain is determining
how a young person 's ability to think
critically and to reason is played out
so the lack of development in that area
is often cited as to explain the
antisocial behavior that children bring
themselves into the juvenile justice
system to begin with and it's that same
underdevelopment of the brain that
places a child at risk of providing
false statements or confessions without
understanding the consequences of what
they're saying and often allowing
themselves to be influenced to just
agree to people um so that they can get
through interview with the law
enforcement or
prosecutors um so it's really important
that representation is there to protect
them um regarding the circumstances of
Children and Families you heard a little
bit about this today but I want to
reiterate the high incidence of
Behavioral disability among these
children puts them at considerable risk
for antagonistic relationships with
their parents or their caregivers
there's also a large population of
children in New Hampshire who are
considered what we call crossover youth
they are actually abused and neglected
children whose behavior is a response to
their B treatment um and we also know
there's an overrepresentation of
children from impoverished circumstances
whose parents May encounter significant
barriers to appearing at court um and
supporting them because of lack of
Transportation or work obligations so
all of those children are highly likely
to be navigating legal systems without
the support of engaged and protective
parents or caregivers um and so the need
for professional U Advocates um and
representation is really critical for
them the most common complaint that we
hear from children when we visit at the
sonunu you Services Center or other
residential facilities where children
are placed is that no one listens to
them we're often astounded when we say
what would you where do you see yourself
what would you like to happen and we
just get blank stairs and the children
invariably tell us I don't no no one has
ever asked me that question they really
are left out of the process and once
their attorneys are gone from the
initial uh delinquency proceedings they
don't you know they may have a visit
from a jppo a juvenile probation parole
officer once a month but they don't have
someone who's really engaged with them
and making sure that their needs are met
appointing legal counsel from the very
beginning for the life of life of a case
increases the chances that children are
going to be heard um and we we rely find
that children make very reasonable often
self-preserving suggestions for their
care um so early and consistent legal
counsel for the life of a case will
ensure that they're listened to and that
they receive any related necessary
treatment and educational services for
optimal Rehabilitation I'll stop there
in the interest of time if you have
questions I'm um um very welcome the
opportunity to answer
them thank you very much are there any
seeing none thank you very much thank
you so I see representative Ned Gordon
has your hand up did you want to testify
on this bill representative Gordon
time needs to representative Gordon
[Music]
representative Gordon did you want to
bill okay hearing nothing appears he can
I know it does but he can he can submit
written testimony if need be um so I am
going
188 than thank you um everyone and just
so we know there were approximately 80
people who signed in in support of this
bill um and there was no one that oo
signed in in
opposition so thank you so up
427 I don't want to have to limit time
so please refrain from testifying for a
half hour okay um and representative
alel I don't have you on my list as
signed up to speak but you're the prime
sponsor so are you do you are you
speaking good morning Madam chair and
yes I filled out the um online sign up
yesterday um to to speak I don't know
why you're not on it but um
anyways I'm gonna call on you first your
bill thank you and I and I will be I
will be very brief and I have emailed uh
my testimony um to all members of the
committee when you get a chance to look
at that um thank you madam chair and uh
welcome everyone I'm so thrilled to be
on this committee um I will begin my
testimony for House Bill 427 by saying
children in New Hampshire deserve to
grow and learn in an environment free
from violence unfortunately we cannot
guarantee that for every child and the
place where they should be the most
protected and safe their home can be a
place of physical sexual and emotional
abuse or tragic neglect as a state we've
made a sincere effort in putting
supports in place to help families
create and sustain safe and nurturing
homes but not everyone is successful in
that endeavor and the state must step in
to protect those children when a child
is taken into State custody it is a
serious decision that is not done in
haste a child removed from their home
has experienced Trauma from the events
leading up to that removal and then
trauma of being taken from their home
the reasons for removing a child are
encap encapsulated in the long studied
body of work of adverse childhood
experiences an adverse childhood
experiences are stressful and traumatic
events that include physical abuse
sexual abuse emotional abuse physical
neglect emotional neglect a mother
treated violently household mental
illness substance misuse in the home the
incarceration of a family member or loss
of a parent an a score is subsequently
calculated by adding up how many of
those experiences apply to a child's
life and compared with a score of zero
people with Ace scores of four have a
400% increased risk of depression are
25% more likely to experience teen
pregnancy and Ace scores of four or more
are 700% more likely to be addicted to
alcohol and are 1,000% more likely to
inject street drugs as documented in the
evidence from doctors FID and Anda whose
public health research developed the
adverse childhood experience experiences
body of work and a score of one of seven
or more in children and adolescents
increases the risk of suicide by 51
times and further 80% of suicide
attempts during childhood and
Adolescence are attributed to Aces
children who experience chronic trauma
suffer delay brain delayed brain
development the consequences of extended
exposure to violence and abuse are found
in
underdevelopment underdevelopment
of cognition social emotional skills and
self-regulation due to that
developmental
trauma corporal punishment as defined in
this
bill part two
B is quoted as means any punishment in
which physical force is issued and
intended to cause some degree of pain or
discomfort that is a description of
trauma nothing in that description is an
appro apprpriate standard of care for
children in state custody it should be
the goal of the state to put an end to
the infliction of trauma on its children
not engage in violence or condone it in
any form therefore I submit House Bill
427 as a step towards ending violence
against children in our custody this
bill was before this committee last
February in the form of House Bill 1250
um for those of you who are new new to
this committee or a new um to the
legislature just a little history this
bill received a recommendation of ought
to pass with a vote of 19 to zero on
February 19th 2020 it sub subsequently
passed the floor of the house on March
11th of 2020 on a Voice vote
unfortunately after covid-19 struck our
state this bill was not chosen to be
absorbed in any of the Senate Omnibus
bills which brings us here for another
try the first sponsor of this important
Pro Child Protection bill was our former
colleague and esteemed member of this
committee The Honorable Dr Skip Baran I
will defer any questions to him and to
the office of the child advocate Dr
Moira O'Neal who is also with us today I
thank you for your time and attention
and for your dedication to the
children and with that um Madam chair I
will defer any questions to me to Dr
Baran uh or Dr MOA O'Neal thank you so
much okay so up next is represent I'm
sorry The
Honorable skip
Baran um to speak in support of the
bill but he's speaking as a member of
the public so it takes a little to get
used to not calling him representative
thank you very much Madame chair um it's
really a pleasure to be back with you
all and in particular I want to
acknowledge uh my pleasure in seeing uh
representative Alisa and representative
licki rejoining this committee we had
many good discussions over important
issues in the past years and it's uh
it's nice to see you back back on the
bench so to speak so
um uh
as as was said um I'm skip Baron I live
in exer and um I'm a retired
pediatrician former professor of
clinical pediatrics at the University of
Connecticut school of medicine and a as
you've heard a three-term member of this
particular committee this fine committee
my interest in the problems associated
with corporal punishment of children
extends back decades when I became aware
of the groundbreaking research of Dr
Murray Strauss at
UNH the topic can raise strong feelings
both pro and con based on personal
experience and family
history but over the past three and a
half decades research has demonstrated
the corporal punishment as a method of
controlling children's behavior is not
only not effective in in the long run
but is associated with long-term serious
consequences which have very significant
social
costs there is strong evidence that
corporal punishment places children at
risk for physical injury poor mental
health slower cognitive
development antisocial behavior and
tolerance of
you will hear more about this in the
accompanying testimony from
International expert Dr DAV David fleor
of unh he will bear these out in more
detail significant studies show us that
the use of corporal punishment is
prevalent in our country again Dr finle
hor recent study shows that young
children in particular are subjected to
Corporal punish ment regularly and it
continues on into
adolescence as you heard last year I
introduced this particular piece of
legislation for several years I sat on
this legislation in an effort to find
the most appropriate approach to ensure
that the state of New Hampshire would
clearly state that it does not condone
the use of corporal
punishment last year the committee as
you
overwhelmingly uh in the committee and
then passed it on to the house without
any
objection unfortunately the pandemic
prevented the Senate from taking up this
bill you may ask if this Corp if this
legislation prohibits corporal
punishment in the home no it does not
prohibit use of corporal punishment in
the
home but with this legislation All State
agencies involved with children will
discourage the use of corporal
punishment in its programs no matter if
these programs are in the public sector
the private sector or carried out in
private
homes with all the accumulated
scientific evidence I ask this committee
to again vote ought to pass and again
affirm that corporal punishment is not
an acceptable method to control
children's
Behavior thank you uh committee thank
you uh chairman uh chairwoman uh rice I
um will be glad to answer any questions
that people
have thank you very much are there any
questions from Mr
Baran M chair representative liwicki
um thank you uh Madam chair thank you Dr
Baran uh I have a question as to how
prevalent is corporal punishment of poor
children who are in under State care is
this uh truly a common issue or is this
unnown or is it already prohibited thank
you um we we certainly don't have any
any um data in regard to that and we
have not perceived that it has been a
specific problem um but we know that
children who are in state care and are
in foster homes are at times have been
subjected to things that we wish would
not happen to children so I can't tell
you that it is that there it is a
prevalent problem in children in state
care but we want to just be absolutely
certain that it doesn't happen to
them thank you Dr bar
representative Banger thank you madam
chairwoman uh Dr Baran are you um aware
of any policies that are in place in
those state agencies that already have
um no corporal punishment in
place to my knowledge there's no
specific policies I will tell you that
certainly um in the uh division of
children youth and and families there
are uh
practices that are encouraged which um
uh to use
alternative to Children's uh behavior
problems so um uh I'm I'm not aware of
specific policies that spell out uh
corporal punishment as being prohibited
um rather I think the um agencies have
taken the approach of these are the ways
that one should um deal with children's
behavior
problems okay are there any further
questions for Mr Baran Dr Baran The
Honorable Baran my friend Mr
Baran all right thank you so much thank
you have a great
day up next is um Moira O'Neal with the
office of the child advocate to speak in
bill
needs she needs to
unmute Miss O'Neal can you unmute I'm
unmuted now can you hear me yes thank
you very good thank you so much Madam
chair members of the committee for
having me back again to support Bill
House Bill 427 prohibiting corporal
punishment of children in state agency
programs um I will defer uh some of the
scientific information that we provided
in um this testimony that you have um in
written form given the expertise that
you've heard um and and also coming um
but also Havey take questions about that
um but I will we'll just in the interest
of time shorten my testimony today a bit
it's the office of the child Advocates
mandate to promote the best interest of
children and by prohibiting corporal
punishment
this bill protects children from the
adverse childhood experiences of
corporal punishment when cared for under
a state contract um currently however we
just want to point out that the
Department of Health and Human Services
has very few contracts for services with
providers such as residential providers
for children um they only have
agreements or reimbursement arrangements
so we would suggest including within the
definition of agency those entities that
have an agreement with the Department of
Health and Human Services and the
Department of Education just to be sure
that it's
covered so I want to comment on what we
know about adverse childhood experiences
that you've heard from representative
iller and honorable skip Baran um
largely because in these conversations
you typically will often hear a response
where someone says well my parents used
corporal punishment on me and I turned
out okay um in the past two decades we
have learned so much about the relation
a ship between these negative
experiences and lifelong problems like
heart disease obesity and depression all
outcomes that none of us would have
anticipated or associated with corporal
punishment so there are things that
happen to people in their lives because
of these experiences as children um that
you might not associate as a bad outcome
um but furthermore as as we all aim to
invest in New Hampshire's future through
its children it's important to note that
corporal punishment has been found to
impact a child's cognitive function and
learning so the verbal methods of
discipline in which caregivers seek to
help children reason or explain the
problem with their behavior can actually
stimulate cognitive cognitive function
and that's what we want we want
children's brains to grow not to recede
in their growth healthy childhood
development is Reliant upon trusting
supportive relationships so children
involved in foster care or state
sponsored institutional care are already
vulnerable because of the adverse
experiences that brought them into the
system into State care we can't expect
them to build those trusting healing
relationships when the people whose job
it is to protect them in the child's
view actually harm them so if we do
promote alternative practices for
discipline um we're not we're investing
in New Hampshire's future um for optimal
outcomes for these children um we don't
believe that there's any care Giver who
intends to harm a child when employing
corporal punishment in fact we know that
most believe although erroneously the
use of corporal punishment will protect
children from harm by teaching them to
curtail dangerous Behavior the fact is
the average parent or caregiver doesn't
have the access to Empirical research or
scientific journals to understand these
outcomes so prohibiting the use of
corporal punishment and state sponsored
care positions the state to model best
practice for parents also holds the
state to a higher standard because the
state has access to the latest science
in any situation where the state
replaces parents or caregivers it's
essential that the state provides care
that's informed by empirical evidence
and of the highest standards of
care um finally we we while the office
of the child advocate appreciates the
purpose behind the Amendments proposed
in the second section of HB 427 we know
that there are some inconsistencies in
RSA 62 76 that's the criminal code that
could be similarly amended to ensure
positive Child Development um it may be
something that the committee wants to um
consider going forward um but otherwise
we support um House Bill 427 um and urge
your uh support for it as well with the
alteration of the definition of agency
um to include those entities that have
agreements with the Department of Health
and Human Services or the Department of
Education thanks for taking my testimony
I welcome your questions if you have
any thank you very much are there any
questions um I see you representative Al
Schiller I don't have a question I'm
gonna try to lower my hand now too sorry
um I don't have a question I just want
to um let the committee know if you're
if you have not seen your email uh there
is an amendment in your email from OS
that addresses exactly what Dr O'Neal
was talking about and it changes line
nine of the
bill um to say entity under contract or
agreement it adds in two words so that's
in your email right now um and I just
you know I figured it would come up at a
exec session but it had just been
referred to so I want to let you know
it's
there great thank you are there any
representative
Banger uh thank you madam chairman
chairwoman I apologize um same question
to you Miss Mor are you familiar with
any uh agencies in the state that
prohibit corporal punishment in their
facility um thank you for the question
we have not seen that specific policy
of thank thank you Miss O'Neal thank
you okay thank you are there any other
questions seeing none thank you very
chair and up next is a representative
Amanda tol to speak in support of the
Bill thank you honorable chairman rice
um chairwoman rice thank you so much um
my name is Amanda Elizabeth tol and I'm
co-sponsoring HB 427 a bill to prohibit
corporal punishment against children in
state care I'm co-sponsoring this bill
because I believe that New Hampshire's
governing bodies have a moral imperative
to act to keep our residents safe
especially our children in state care
who are our youngest and most vulnerable
Granite
sters corporal punishment against
children is a tragedy that severely
damages both their physical and their
emotional well-being this is a fact
supported by Major children's rights
Advocates including the American Academy
of Pediatrics the science is clear
children who are taught that violence is
a solution are overwhelmingly more
likely to become aggressive adults and
themselves violent perpetrators Banning
corporal punishment against children is
not a new idea many countries across the
world have banned this practice
including many democracies such as
Sweden France Germany Finland Denmark
and Iceland and Norway just to name a
few the idea of Legally harming children
in state care children who are often
poor and are disproportionately likely
to have experienced previous trauma is
appalling I think the vast majority of
New Hampshire constituents regardless of
party affiliation would support this
bill we share the fundamental belief
that our children should be kept safe I
cannot emphasize this enough children
who are under the care of the state have
already experienced some form of trauma
it is the responsibility of the State of
New Hampshire to protect our children
from any more physical emotional or
psychological harm that is why I'm
asking you to support HB 427 thank
you thank you very much representative
are there any questions for
representative
toll seeing none thank you very much for
you okay up next please forgive me for
what I'm about to do to this first
name
resi
Oro hello Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical
Center child advocacy and Protection
Program to speak in support of this
bill uh good morning uh Madame chair and
committee chairs and
representatives uh I would like to speak
in support of uh House Bill 427 as well
as the Director of the child advocacy
and protection program at Children's
Hospital at
darkmouth um I believe uh and literature
uh supports that the more violence there
is uh in any Community the more Corporal
in are you
there indicate that uh 80 to 90% of
families in the United States approve of
corporal punishment uh in the family
against children uh however again uh
research both in the United States and
in many other countries uh show that
corporal punishment in fact has only one
positive uh impact on the outcome
compared to 10 other impacts which uh
end up with uh very negative outcomes
The only positive impact of corporal
punishment is immediate immediate comp
compliance with what the caretaker is
requesting on the other hand
um other things that we would like to
come out of child discipline positive
child discipline are impacted very
negatively uh the child morally
internalizes that it is okay uh to hit
other people when they don't comply with
what you want the quality of the
relationship between the child and the
caretakers uh is impacted very
negatively child's mental health is
affected negatively which leads to poor
adult mental health as a result of
corporal punishment becoming one of the
adverse childhood experiences as uh
multiple individuals mentioned this
morning child becomes more aggressive
because they roll model after their
caretaker who is acting as an aggressor
rather than an educator in their
relationship with the child child
internalizes antisocial behaviors as
they grow up and they become violent
individuals who also uh approve of
corporal
punishment which has a very fine line uh
toward physical abuse uh obviously
corporal punishment almost
overwhelmingly all the time occurs as a
result of the caretaker being very angry
with the child's behavior and there is
no guarantee that a child who is
corporally punished will not be
physically abused uh if the caretaker uh
loses
control um and as I mentioned uh these
children uh tend to grow up to become
adult aggressors adults with antisocial
behaviors and with Tendencies to abuse
their own child and even their spouse
when literature has supported all of
these uh as a Child Abuse Prevention
worker uh I have always been against any
kind of corporal
punishment uh but in the context of this
house uh bill
uh the State starting taking the steps
toward Banning corporal punishment at
least in state agencies and in uh Foster
placement is not only going to be a
wonderful step toward educating our
entire state
population but also will role model
toward uh foster parents
observing how things move more
positively when they do not use corporal
punishment with their foster children I
am hoping that they will also become
individuals practicing positive
parenting with their own children and
will voluntarily choose not to use
corporal punishment with their own
children thank you very much uh Madame
chairman chairperson and um I'm open to
any questions and
comments thank you very much for your
questions okay seeing none thank you
very much thank
you okay that's it for my list and I
see oh wait a
minute okay so next up we have Rebecca
Ross good morning Madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
I'm Rebecca Ross General councel and
legislative leison for dcyf I just
wanted to provide um a response to the
question that was asked of whether or
not we have any policies regarding this
and um there is a Prohibition of
corporal punishment in both our foster
care licensing rules and Residential
Care LIC licensing rules that we can
up thank you very much Miss Ross are
there any questions any further
long thank you madam chair uh I the uh
foster care and Residential Care are
yes it's it's a Prohibition of anyone
providing Foster Residential Care from
using corporal punishment okay and the
same has
um with starting on line uh on line 19
of the bill to prevent injury other than
to prevent injury yourself or others
that's that's all
consistent I believe it's consistent I
will have to pull the actual rules and
compare the language to say that it's
identical okay and you'll be sending
that to us correct yes okay thank you
you're
welcome thank you representative Banger
uh thank you madam
chairwoman um Miss Ross question to you
um in order to obtain a license these
residential programs um in foster care
programs are they required to adhere to
427 um yes so they're they're informed
and trained on the rules and what the
requirements are in need to agree to
that to obtain a license and then if
they were to in fact violate those rules
once there were licensed and a child was
placed then we would have the ability to
investigate and take action on that
license if they were
inconsistent follow up follow up so just
to be clear if they um did not adhere to
those policies and guidelines set by the
division they would in fact lose their
it would depend um obviously there's you
know a lot of facts that this would
depend on but certainly um the most
extreme result would be loss of that
license or revocation there could also
be a corrective action plan if there was
a misunderstanding or um lack of clarity
so I wouldn't want to say that every
time the issue raised it would
automatically result in a loss of a
license they would have process they
would have a right to a hearing to
determine whether or not they did in
fact violate the rules but essentially
if someone is not going to agree to not
use corporal punishment they would not
be licensed they would not be able to
maintain a license they would not be an
appropriate
provider thank you thank you m
representative leki uh thank you madam
chair thank you um Mr um are there
children in state custody who are not
already covered by the policies just
mentioned
not that are in one of the dcyf
placements there could be educational
placements or uh mental health or
Behavioral Health placements that I
can't speak to but certainly not in DCF
care and custody and in our
placements thank
you are there any further
any other speakers and there's no one
else on my list so I'm going to close
the public hearing on um House
Bill
427 and we will
be in recess for lunch until 1 o'clock
please come back a few minutes early so
we can make sure oh I'm sorry
representative
long thank you madam chair are we is it
the same link to get back in at one as
we did at 9:30 yes yes it is okay great
you can stay on I mean you know you can
just um you know put up your picture or
whatever and just mute yourself you
don't you don't have to sign out okay
great okay thank you representative
Alysia Madam chair do you have the
numbers for support in opposition
possibly do I'm sorry so there were
there were uh 22 people signed in in
support of um HB 427 and no one signed
in in opposition thank you very much
thank you for the reminder no problem
okay so everyone enjoy your lunch and
we'll see you back at one o'clock thanks
so much I really think today's gone
pretty smooth so I I appreciate it
everybody thank you we'll see you in a
little bit representative rice yes um
could I have I'm happy to mute this the
um the feed so that folks can talk
during lunch um could I just have a
volunteer to unmute before you resume
the
meeting sure if I know how to do that
well you have my number if you if you if
anyone struggles with it to um
unmute representative D come back so she
believes so but I'll text you if we have
a problem right sounds good enjoy your
okay
guys
e
hi Scott here's my sound check just
checking to see if you can hear
me maybe all the way across the
room Christina can you hear me yes I
okay how we doing here Christina can you
you
me can you hear
me I can hear you can you hear me I'm
all Associated cost is completely can
you hear me now additional cost in other
words it could give the impression that
the cost of the contract is much higher
than it it truly is or new C uh cost now
if the legislation is aimed at giving
the public a chance to oppose a contract
for whatever reason then it's important
all testing testing Can You Hear Me yes
can you hear
me I can I just got to tweak it a little
bit if you don't mind stay on okay not
at all
okay Christina can you try it again yes
can you hear
me yeah are you talking right into your
mic you're very uh
faint okay you talking right into your
now that you're attain I thank you for
your time consideration and thank you
off your continued service during these
times uh we don't have any panelists we
do have one more speaker that has their
hands up
Brian
better thank you Mr chairman can you
hear me all
right yes okay
chairman Christina can you hear me
better
okay just trying to put my mic up a
little bit
better yes thank you okay terrific um so
feedback
not issue
[Music]
points and
yeah that sounds good can you hear me
now
[Music]
um it's a little more muffled but I can
hear
[Music]
that that's pretty good yeah I can hear
you
[Music]
thank
you
e
me yes okay they can hear me wait wait
wait no that has to be turned off
now all right we're
okay welcome back
everyone before we go on to um House
Bill
254 um I would
like
to have us vote on sending HB 188 to LBA
to get a fiscal
note we need a majority of the committee
to send it there and I I think it's
important that it it go get the fiscal
note otherwise I'm concerned it's going
to end up killed later down the road
because we don't want to leave the
Judiciary in a bad position financially
either so does everybody understand what
I'm
saying yes or no
yeah okay
um
so does anybody want to speak to that
other than me
or sorry I've never done this before so
bear with
me yes representative
Banger
representa can you please move
very thank you
this okay representative
long thank you madam chair I I uh had to
log back in because I had lost my audio
for some reason so what was the question
so um I would like to send HB 188 to LBA
for a fiscal note they never it um
and I just think it's the responsible
thing to do yeah no I agree I mean
although we're just a policy yeah yeah
why not right but I don't want to send
it on and have it get killed because it
doesn't have it do you know what I mean
I sure that way it can go to finance and
they can put the money there for it so I
would okay I would feel
better so um would anyone else like to
representative
AEL yes um let me lower my hand thank
you Madame chairwoman I'm just curious
while it's at LBA are we do we have to
just put a pin in it exec it later or
can we move forward and then whatever
comes from LBA send it along to
finance just procedurally how do we but
I'm not going to execute today anyway
but so I get a more definite I mean it
would have to go quickly
because it would be a sec then a second
committee bill which honestly is why I
originally scheduled it first because um
I really thought it would would go to
finance um so but I've already spoken to
the speaker um and said you know I want
this to to go there I I just think it's
the right thing to do so um do does
anybody else have a a comment or a
it okay so representative Alysia could
you please call the role on this we we
have to have a majority to be able to
send it and then I I'm just going to
take two minutes to call
um Pam back because she's only here till
two
o'clock of
course representative D
representative
yella there
yes representative lucki
yes representative
Banger thank you representative Alia
representative
Lichfield
Smith representative
long
yes representative Alisa
here representative Gman oh not not a
here it's a yes or a
no I'm sorry I meant to say yes excuse
me
uh representative grman
L
yes representative
W
pres it's a yes or a no
yes Representative patri no
yes representative Al Al
Schiller alt Schiller and
yes okay three four
five and the chair votes yeah 11 12 and
um Madame chair representative rice yes
okay so we're just missing two yeah so
but that was unanimous for everyone here
yes okay so give me we're going to
recess just for two minutes
I'm just going to make this call and
we'll be right back on thank you okay
thank
you so those that are in the room I'm
except for the chairwoman I'm having a
hard time hearing them I don't know if
that yeah very
barely hey I can barely hear
representative
Banger representative bander can you say
something
please sorry the chairwoman had asked me
to hang on can you hear me okay or is it
a tad but uh you're much quieter I mean
I have to really I turned my computer up
loud so now everybody's really loud but
you're still
soft can you hear us are all microphones
room just one more time can you hear me
okay now I hear you better now thank
you but don't be offended if I ask you
to repeat something okay so just do me a
favor if either one of you wants to
speak just pull the microphone to speak
okay okay was that two minutes because
I'm
done
so
um all right so I am now oh no I'm not
you are representative gon yes you're
opening this hearing remember yes um I
am going
to at
uh 109 open the hearing on House Bill
254 relative to the placement of minors
in Secure setting and at this time I
will ask
uh
representative Tim Rice to present for
chair mam Vice
chair for the record I'm representative
Kim rice I represent um the District of
Hudson and
pelum and I bring for your
consideration House Bill 254
in
2017 we had a very long and lengthy
public hearing on a bill that would
significantly reduce the the size of the
number of kids placed at the cuni
Center and at that time I was
significantly opposed to the end result
because I was deeply
concerned that we would have a lot of
Youth running the
streets without having having the
services they needed in their
communities to help keep the public and
the kids
safe much to my joy I was proven
wrong this has been tremendously
successful for these kids they um as of
today I believe the the number of kids
placed at the senuna Youth Services
Center is eight as opposed to the over
100 kids that were there in 2017
what HB 254 does is um adds more
offenses to the list that kids sh can be
placed out in their communities getting
services in the communities they know
rather than being committed to the
sununu
center um I'd also like to um bring
forth in your email is a an amendment I
um it what the amendment does is it's
going to add six first of all it's going
to make it so that the kids that are
detained at cunu can also be
um cannot be detained for these same
offenses but it's going to put it out
six months later than the effective date
so that the courts
um have time to you know get used to
what's going on and and make the the
changes that they need
um
and so that's really about it I have
more people that will have you know more
answers to your questions when when they
testify so I'm going to defer to them
but um when this was brought to my
attention I was very happy to sponsor it
because I was so dead set against it
before but I am I'm very happy that I
was wrong and I say that it's really
important that we have these kids in
their communities and now that the
services are there more um I think it's
important for the the kids going forward
so on that
note if you don't mind I would like to
defer the questions to the person that's
going to come on after
me okay thanks for your time thank you
representative rice um the next person
Joy John you
know thank you madam chair good
afternoon Madam chair members of the
committee it's a pleasure to be before
the uh Shon family law committee albe it
virtually uh I rise today in support of
House Bill
254 uh as representative R just stated
as relative to the placement of miners
in insecure
facilities um my testimony today will
refer to the amendment that
representative rice just spoke to the
amendment replaces the entire uh bill
and I will explain the differences
between the two and the reasoning uh
behind
it I come today representing w point and
the juvenile reform project uh Waypoint
which was formerly known as child and
Family
Services um has been an operation since
1850 and you heard mention this morning
by Mr skibby of the juvenile reform
project I have forwarded testimony to
all of you I'm going to do my best to um
excerpt the testimony and not read
it
um so to speak to the actual amendment
to get into what this what this does and
what this doesn't do there are three key
sections three key sections in the
amendment sections two three and
four and I'm going to speak to them uh
I'll speak to section four first because
that's the perhaps the most impactful as
representative rice stated back in 2017
this committee made changes to
offenses whereby a child could be
Center this makes further changes to
offenses that a child can be
incarcerated for at the sen Services
hour and what this does is it limits
incarceration
to Serious violent offenses as outlined
I won't go through the specific um
offenses unless people have questions
but they're outlined here I will point
out to you that in the amendment um the
bulk of section four is existing
language the changes to the language
begin down uh where it gets into the
specific offenses but everything else in
there uh should be existing language so
as of January 1st of
2022 this would go into effect if you um
ordained to pass it and children who
were committed would um have committed a
a significant a higher level of
offense going to section
two section two is in regards to the
Detention of
children I I'm sure you all know this
given being on this committee but I'll
point it out that commitment is when the
child is effectively convicted and
incarcerated detention is when a child
is held by court order while awaiting
trial so in section two what that does
standards so today a child can be
detained only for reasons that they can
be committed is what the current
language says um we want to
maintain the the children who can be
today for the first six months that this
is in
effect the reason for that and I'll get
into some of the specific programs but
the reason for that as representative
rice stated is we would like to give the
court and the department more time uh to
roll out their system of care that
they're working on now and more time to
um more time to acclimate to these
changes so between January of 22 and
July 1st of
2022 any child who is detained today can
be detained
then section three which doesn't go into
effect until July 1 of
2022 says a child can only be detained
if they can be committed meaning it
raises the the level for detention to
the higher level offense as Inc
commitment
the other pieces are the statement of
findings and then the um the effective
does why is this why is this bill
important well the bill is important for
a for a number of reasons first as you
heard the OCA testify this morning you
also heard a number of other uh
Witnesses testify that uh kids don't do
well when they're in erated it is not an
effective
intervention generally for children and
um there are there are significant
adverse effects when children are
incarcerated um Dropout rates increase
we see um increased trauma uh we see
kids often become more engaged with the
adult correction
system um and keep in mind that as uh
the OCA also testified this morning a
number of these children at sinunu are
what she referred to as crossover kids
I've never heard that but they're kids
that grow out of the abuse neglect
system and into the Juvenile Justice
System it's important to keep in mind
that as representative rice indicated in
2017 there were significant questions
about whether there were services to
treat the kids that we were keeping out
of
sonunu um that was uh that was a major
topic of discussion what I would point
out to you today is we're in a very
different place um the fedal families
first legislation went into effect a
couple of years ago uh it's required to
be fully implemented by October of this
year what that requires is to treat
children in the
community unless um congregate care is
the only solution it will it will
emphasize community- based care which is
why you all uh two years ago enacted s
sp14 the state system of care bill and
um funded it with $20 million because
that
bill permits the department to build out
its system of care in order to comply
with the family first
legislation I'll also say that the the
broad system of care which focuses in
the G on community based care is good
for our
kids and it will have a longas
impact and that's why this time is right
to bring this bill forward all of these
things are coming online uh currently
this legislation before you in fact uh
doesn't become effective for several
months after the system of care is built
out so the system will be in a very
different place than it was in
2017 uh today we run between it you
heard representative R say the senses is
eight I've seen the senses as high as 15
or 16 in the last you know six to eight
months that's the the range it's been in
it's it's been uh about half committed
kids and half detained kids
typically what this legislation will
likely do is at least have that
more um we believe that that this
legislation creates an opportunity to
continue to move away from the use of
institutional and conate Care in the
state
and emphasize on treating kids in their
Community because what we know is that
any child committed to sinunu will be
returning to their community at some
point they don't learn to be effective
community members when they're in jail
they learn to be effective community
members by having supported um treatment
in the community where they can actually
try out what they're learning and so
with that um I'm happy to answer any
questions the committee might have and I
would ask the committee to um please
pass the um the legislation as as
amended uh before
you thank you very
much okay are there any questions for
John Joy okay so we have representative
long representative long thank you madam
chair uh Mr Dy uh this has no effect on
contracts without Estates correct with
Center um I'm not sure I understand the
question representative could you
rephrase that well well do if we
contract with children being placed from
out of state would this have an effect
on them do would would they would we
have you know so let's say there's a
child in incarceration in
Vermont
um that doesn't fall under any of these
um would we be able to contract with
them being at the sonuna
center so you're talking about placing
uh incarcerated kids from other states
in the Sonona Center
correct okay um so my understanding I am
not a lawyer but my understanding is
that this applies to Children um
arrested and convicted in the state of
New
Hampshire I do not believe it applies to
other contracts although I would defer
to Mr ribom or someone else who who
might have a better handle on that
um I'm getting a text sorry um getting a
text that I'm trying to interpret um so
I don't I don't believe it stops kids
from Vermont but representative long I
that okay thank you okay I'm being told
by an attorney I work with that my
statement is correct that this does not
impact kids from the contract bringing
kids in from Vermont I would say for the
committee's benefit is my understanding
that contract only extends till October
of 2021 when Vermont expects to have
their own program and this does not go
into effect until
January
testimony and uh representative
representative lck
Madam chair would it be appropriate for
us now to vote to replace the uh bill as
passing to the m no we handle that in um
during our work session ex session
yeah are there any further questions
from Mr
dejoy right seeing none thank you very
much thank you our next person to speak
will be Mr Michael Skiby can you please
introduce
on can you please introduce yourself Mr
Skiby and let us know where you're
from yes thank you uh uh Madam chair and
members of the committee my name is
Michael skibby I'm the policy director
at the disability rights Center and also
um part of the juvenile reform project
um I want to thank thank representative
rice for her sponsorship of this bill um
you've been a long time support Mr we're
having a hard hearing you can you speak
up a little please yes how about that um
thank you I want to thank representative
rice for her uh sponsorship of this bill
she's been a longtime supporter of um
reform of the Juvenile Justice System um
and we very much appreciate that um the
disability rights Center supports the
bill as it is being proposed to be
modified by the chair's Amendment
because it will reduce the use of the
sununu center um particularly for minor
offenders which research shows is
associated with lower recidivism and
better outcomes for children families
and Public Safety um I'm not going to
say very much because it's been said
already and I don't want to um repeat um
that testimony but I do want to
emphasize a couple of things there's
been some mention about how the effects
of Correction placement for children can
be quite negative it is especially
negative for children who are minor
offenders um the relationship between
how we respond to minor offenses and how
the kids who commit those offenses in
the future is very striking um when
you're talking about Minor offenders as
compared to to more serious offenders a
child who's just starting to get into
minor trouble is often someone who with
the right intervention can do very well
in the future and there's lots of
stories of people who've had just minor
contact
with the justice system who went on to
live successful lives without further
Court involvement those interventions
are often most successful when they do
not remove a child from their home in
school because those removals can weaken
and sever the connections that are
protective against antisocial Behavior
now those are connections with peers who
are pro-social with your own family with
teachers and coaches at school who are
um providing helpful guidance to a child
particularly a child with a disability
who may be risk of
delinquency these effects are less
striking however with more serious
offenders who may need more intense
interventions so there it is definitely
true that Corrections placement should
be um avoided whenever possible when
it's not necessary to protect the child
or to protect the community but the the
difference is most striking when you're
talking about the kinds of offenders
that this bill would remove from
eligibility for placement at the sununu
center and that's um that's one of the
reasons that uh we strongly support this
bill
um I think that everything else has been
said um I I just comment that New
Hampshire's reduced use of interventions
like the cunu
center um runs in parallel with what has
been happening nationally um um from
2003 to 2015 the rate of use of
Corrections placements for children went
down by
53% now part of that was a deliberate
change in policy in many states just
like New Hampshire has decided that it's
better and more cost effective to reduce
the use of facilities like the sununu
center but it also it is also because
there's been a significant reduction in
demand on the juvenile just justice
system as a whole because the juvenile
crime rate just like the adult crime
rate has been in Decline since the 1990s
the arrest nationally of children went
down by 50% from 2006 to 2019 I don't
have an exact statistic for New
Hampshire but it's I've certainly seen
statistics in New Hampshire that show
we've had a significant decline in the
number of delinquency petitions that are
brought and the number of cases that
have been brought into court over that
same period of time so I'd ask you for
your support of the bill as amended I
think the amendment is very key to uh
making this bill work um successfully um
it will be um better for kids
um and a more effective use of scarce
public resources be happy to answer any
questions thank you Mr Skiby do we have
any questions for Mr
Skiby seeing none um I thank you very
much for your time and information and
the next person we'll speak with will be
Rebecca
ra if you Rebecca can unmute
good afternoon yes thank you madam chair
members of the committee can you hear me
all
right great thank you um for the record
my name is Rebecca Ross I'm general
counsel and legislative gazon for
DCF um we are not taking a position on
this bill but we did want to provide
some some background information um in
advance of the hearing I provided a
number of documents via email to the
committee's researcher I hope you have
those or we'll have them shortly
um we also have Erica angelli from
children's Behavioral Health on the
hearing today who can answer questions
related to behavioral health to the
extent those arise as well um to start
with we just wanted to provide some some
background and two of the documents I
provided were from dcf's data book um
both page 8 and Page 20 Page 20 looks at
the use of sununu Center and as you look
at that it will reflect exactly what you
heard the other um folks testify today
that the use of syse has decreased
dramatically since 2016 through fiscal
year 2020 which is reflected in there
last year the average daily census was
16.9 and in the last few months we've
seen slightly lower numbers as well um
so we want to make sure that as we're
making further changes to who can be
committed that we avoid any unintended
consequences and understand where we're
starting from if we're going to continue
to make shifts um a couple additional
facts from the data book that I think
are relevant are that um last year there
were about 1,700 delinquency cases of
those delinquency
cases less than 400 were in placement of
that number in replacement a much
smaller portion were committed to syc so
that's what we're talking about a very
very small number of cases and folks and
the question is where should that line
be drawn on who who can get in I think
that the offenses that are listed are
absolutely appropriate murder attempted
murder
um aggravated fonus sexual
assault no question those have already
been identified as the serious violent
offenses um and we heard testimony about
Minor offenses but the question for you
really
is what's in between and how should
those be treated because um the most
serious
offenses are identified the minor
offenses already are not coming in the
door to
syc but have we drawn that line in this
bill so
narrowly that we are going to be um
removing the safety net in cases that we
need it so an additional document that I
provided you with and I don't know if
all of the members of the committee are
familiar with this or not but it's the
Court's detention screening instrument
that is used every time the court is
asked to issue a detention order and
attached to the instructions which are
also provided is a list of all of the
offenses and how they rank and how they
are considered and a thoughtful group of
folks including defense attorneys went
through and amended that effective July
2019 to really rank the risk level
associated with different offenses and
you'll see on that list that there are a
number of tier 2
offenses um that are um certainly very
intimate offenses personal offenses
against other individuals that are not
included on the list for which um
commitment is contemplated in this bill
now this Bild as representative rice
said it's to encourage treatment in the
community and all youth who are within
the delinquency system or
absolutely have the ability to Avail
themselves of treatment in the community
what this is really looking at is who
can we treat in a secure facility when
that's absolutely necessary
and so the another document that I
provided is a list of the statutory
Provisions related to some of those tier
2 felony offenses in the description of
what they are for example we have a
number of Youth at syc that are there
for simple assault and if you look at
our definition of simple assault it does
include bodily injury and there are kids
who are not eligible to be in any other
residential program because they will
not accept them because of their AG Rive
Behavior now whether or not simple
assault fits into the list of Minor
offenders I think you have to look at
the facts and circumstances of that and
to remove that ability from the judge um
for that small number of Youth that
we're talking about should be carefully
considered so I would ask you to
consider that list looking specifically
at things like human trafficking
offenses against minors under 13
domestic violence is not included in
that list resisting arrest and causing
bodily injury to an officer is not
included in that list there are a number
of things that if we're removing from
that list we need to
consider what the outcome of that would
be um looking at the purpose of 169c the
delinquency um statute it includes
providing protection care treatment
counseling supervision and
rehabilitative resources
the department is absolutely committed
to buiing those in the least restrictive
most appropriate environment we just
want to make sure that we are not
narrowing the system too much that we
don't Avail ourselves at to the most
appropriate setting for some of these
youth so in considering the unintended
consequences of this bill if we are
looking at not allowing commitment for
some of these offenses that are not
included um
we risk having um youth that cannot be
placed anywhere because their aggressive
behaviors prevent them from being placed
in other residential facilities again
we're talking about a very small number
of people but we do think those folks
exist um as well
as how will the rest of the system
respond and we would be concerned that
if
prosecutors in the criminal justice
system believe that um the delinquency
system is not responding we will
actually see an increase in the number
of petitions to certify 16 and 17 year
olds as adults and move them prematurely
into the adult system because the
juvenile system is not responsive enough
and we would have concerns about not
being able to
provide a rehabilitative system through
delinquency and forcing kids at an
earlier age into a more punitive adult
system where they would actually be
detained at syu for a longer period of
time pending
certification um and potentially face
transitioning to the adult correction
system when they age out um and if we
narrow the system too much we risk
seeing that uh we also are concerned
that we decrease the ability to reach
settlements in some of these cases where
we see second deegree assaults or
aggravated fonus sexual assault pled
down to simple assault knowing that the
individual will be able to get the
treatment they need in a secured
facility and um considering victims in
the community if that is no longer an
option are we going to see a reluctance
to um enter into agreements and actually
be pushing toward a more punitive or
higher level offense which I think would
be an unintended unintended consequence
of this bill um so in addition to those
concerns about what will happen to that
small number of kids in between that may
not be minor offenders but aren't on the
list contemplated in the bill as
proposed um as well as the timing we
just ask for you to thoughtfully
consider if this is where the line needs
to be drawn at this time I'm happy to
questions
thank any questions from Miss
Ross uh representative
thank you madam Vice chair
um to Miss Ross this is representative
overridden um I don't have that in front
of me I we could reach out to the courts
to ask for that information they track
all of the the um screen
instruments okay thank
you representative Lui uh thank you
madam shair um my question is if we are
going to take people out of tuno I've
been doing a lot about the use of
restraints in other facilities and might
be putting kids into a situation where
another facility blessing facility would
restrain I think that's one of the
concerns that that
facilities have to assess their risk and
the ability to keep kids safe and one of
the reasons why they may not accept a
youth is because they don't feel like
they have the tools to keep them safe um
and don't want to be in violation of the
restraint and seclusion laws and don't
have the ability to have a um
them thank you Miss Ross we appreciate
your
time um next we will
to Michelle
meris um thank you Michelle if you could
unmute yourself
please and welcome can you introduce
yourself please sure thank you very much
hopefully everyone can hear me uh Madam
chair and honorable members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Michelle Merritt I'm the president and
CEO of new Futures can you hear me can
you speak a little louder please I will
try can is this any better yes thank you
you sure um I'm the president and CEO of
new Futures we're a nonprofit
nonpartisan Health policy and advocacy
organization uh located in conquered but
uh doing work Statewide our mission is
to improve the health and wellness of
all granite sters and for the past
several years we've managed a policy
agenda with a very specific uh focus on
children's Behavioral Health uh in this
role we have also participated as a
member of the juvenile reform project
which has been mentioned by some of the
previous speakers
and we too support the bill with the
amendment previously described uh the
previous speakers Did a a great job of
outlining exactly why this is important
um the only thing that I will add is
that as the department works towards
full implementation of the reforms in
Senate bill 14 which are the reforms
around the children's system of care um
we believe that the array of Community
Based Services available to support
these children who are multi-stem
involved and require significant mental
health supports will be available um and
again as the other speakers have said we
strongly believe that connecting these
children to clinically appropriate
Community Based Services is a more
Humane and a better alternative to
incarceration for many of them and we
know the outcomes are better when
children can remain in their communities
um and it's better for their long-term
Health as well so I'll yield the rest of
my time I think the other speakers have
covered it well but I'm happy to answer
any questions that U committee members
may have thank you very much thank you m
May uh does anybody have any
[Music]
question seeing none I want to thank
everybody and um I will turn it over to
representative n chair
rut okay so um
because so now I've had everyone who has
signed up to speak if there is anyone on
the attendees list who wants to speak if
you raise your hand and we will be sure
to get your testimony but the the people
I've called on are the people who I had
on my list so if there's any additional
testimony please raise your hand and we
angelli can you unmute please Erica and
introduce yourself
good morning everybody or good afternoon
everybody it's not morning uh Erica
gelli I am the director for the Bureau
for children's Behavioral Health at the
Department of Health and Human
Services um I just wanted to add a
little uh additional information from
what Rebecca Ross had said um I reviewed
the uh bill I have not yet seen the
amendment um uh from the description of
the amendment it sounds as though one of
the requirements around the Care
Management entity has been uh taken out
and if that's the case that's fine we do
um through the Care Management entity
accept any children referrals for
children who require that intensive
level communitybased support um that
would include that does include any
child in involved in the Juvenile
Justice System um already so uh we don't
necessarily need a requirement around
that um and I just wanted to reiterate
some of the concerns that Rebecca Ross
had stated around the
um one or two instances where we've had
uh children with very intensive needs
and have had some real aggression issues
um become sort of uh either stuck at an
emergency department or at a psychiatric
hospital um for longer periods of time
than uh we anybody would want them to be
there um and trying to find the next
best treatment um option for them um so
that's just a little uh information that
we have seen happen in the system today
we are working really hard on all of
those uh requirements within s sp14 and
to broaden the bench of Behavioral
Health supports for all children who
require them in New Hampshire um a lot
of those uh areas will be implemented
very soon and that will help for sure
but again as Rebecca Ross had stated
there are going to be those one or two
uh couple of uh children that we've seen
come through that really requires uh
something more intense a little more
secure than what we have today and what
we still may not have in the future once
we've implemented all of our
requirements and um so that's just uh an
example we have seen uh to date and
we'll likely see again um in the future
uh at any given time
questions thank you I do see one
question
un hi thank you for um taking my
question Madame Vice chair um related to
those situations where people are left
in the emergency rooms for long periods
of time um are there any solutions for
that population right now in the works
and
yes absolutely we have a number of
different interventions that we are um
currently working on implementing and I
I'll am happy to go through the list
um we I'm happy to report that under
usual circumstances this is not happen a
lot for children in New Hampshire um
we're seeing the rise of numbers of kids
at emergency departments I think because
of covid um so the numbers are higher
now than what we're used to so under
normal circumstances we don't run into
these uh situations where children are
at um emergency departments for long
periods of time that's the good news um
what we are doing uh to address those
issues are the first thing is we are
working to implement and very close
close to implementing stage one of
Statewide mobile crisis for children so
that with the hopes that children and
adults alike will not have to go to the
emergeny departments in the first place
to address their Behavioral Health
crisis um secondly there we have
expanded greatly the our intensive
Community Based programming that is uh
implemented by our Care Management
entities of which we have two in the
State um so our numbers in that
intensive Community Based programming
has risen from 100 well up over 200 uh
children being served in those that
program right now and that's the program
that we refer to as fast
forward we also are including another
program uh in the book of business of
the Care Management entities to follow
children in residential treatment to be
able to um help transition appropriately
back to their home Community um we are
also uh going through a complete
Residential Treatment transformation
work this is uh spurred on by a number
of different things one being the
federal uh fames first legislation that
you heard a little bit about today um
the 10-year Mental Health Plan and the
Child Welfare uh transformation
recommendations all uh aligned to um
give us the impetus to redo the entire
residential treatment system in New
Hampshire where we will have five
different levels of care that will
hopefully meet most if not all of the
needs of the children in New Hampshire
so we don't have children going out of
state we don't have children lingering
list thank Miss do I see any more
bander thank you Madame Vice chair um
question to Erica I apologize I can't
read your last name and I don't want to
busher it I
apologize
sorryi
yes okay um in in regards to the you
referenced the number of kids in the
eerc rooms do you know do you know off
the top of your head the data that you
have regarding how many kids entering
the ER or Juvenile Justice kids or Just
Kids excuse me children entering the ERS
with private insurance for mental health
reasons certainly I don't have the uh
breakdown of children who may be
Juvenile Justice involved we do have the
breakdown of children who are enrolled
in Medicaid vers commercial insurance
and we'd be happy to uh send that
you thank you you're welcome any further
questions I see no hands and nobody's
trying to get my attention so we thank
you very much for your testimony and
information thank
you thank you very much I don't see
anyone else Madam chair who wishes to
testify I don't see anyone else who has
any questions Madam chair so I will um
entertain a motion to
[Music]
close I'm just gonna close the hearing
on house did um rep D Simone yes can you
do you have the list of people that
signed up to support and oppose be
without
testifying yes could you read that
before we close this will so we had 20
people that signed in in
support and nobody signed
in again in opposition
y does that question representative
your yes thank you very much very
welcome okay all right everybody um
thank you so much we appreciate your
time your patience um I think it went
pretty good so I hope you all have a
great day and we'll see you back here
next week and we'll do it
again
okay so have a great night drive safe
bye bye hey I wanted to yeah I I wanted
to ask on uh so I see we have a
Wednesday on the 2nd I believe yes um so
so do we know if there's going to be a
day or two days that we could block out
well we're working on that right now um
the problem we're running into is there
are some committees that need two or
three days because they have so many
early
bills so for the next few weeks we're
not going to really have a a blocked day
I am trying for Thursdays it just turned
out that originally we weren't going to
meet next week because they they needed
all the days for the um committees that
have early bills but because they ended
up having that one day they offered it I
took it because I don't want us to get
you know really far behind and feel
rushed in our work so um I did that but
I I am going to try for Thursdays but
right now everything is just such a work
in progress that you know we're
trying so and another question are we
still sticking to if you're a co-pa
answer you can't ask
questions because I asked a question and
I'm a co- so I should have done so we're
gonna we're gonna stick with that we are
but you know I mean listen it was our
first day and I think we all did pretty
good yeah it was done well thank you you
know um I think that you know we things
are going to happen but we'll do our
best to you know stay on top of it all
it's it's so hard with us in separate
places and over the computer computer
and everything but hopefully hopefully
we're we're on the other side of this
pandemic and and you know now that we
have the vaccine and everything will be
start getting better for us and we'll be
able to breathe again with no masks
it'll be nice but um yeah so does
anybody else have any other questions so
can I leave representative Long's
question
on because I put it in the notes oh
sure go ahead okay yeah I'll make a
motion to censor
him that darn representative
long all right well have a great night